foreign
to figure out how to lose weight and
keep it up permanently After
experiencing those sexual trauma and the
back story I was raped when I was 16
years old I'm so sorry that somebody
took that everything away from you
especially taking away how safe you feel
inside your own body
[Music]
hey oh this is John with the Dr John
deloney show I'm so glad you're joining
us
I really do I hope you're having a great
week
hope your week is good hope you're
reading something important hope you
have the news mostly off I hope you are
so far away from the political Madness
and insanity and stupidity
you're just focusing on your friends and
your community and your kids and your
significant other
I'll even give you this hope you're
hanging out with your pets hope you all
are having pet time whatever's going on
in your world I hope you're doing well
if you're playing live music I hope
you're playing cards hope you're doing
things that bring you Joy and make you
smile
and I hope you're doing well at work and
if you're not that's all right we all
have seasons ups and downs that's where
the show's for we talk to real people
going through real challenges whether
mental and emotional health whether it
is Crisis whether it's suicidality
whatever you got going on this I'm here
and we're gonna sit there and we're
gonna figure it out together if you want
to be on the show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask ask and please don't forget
doesn't cost anything it's totally free
takes just a few seconds of your time it
makes a huge difference if you leave us
a review if you're watching this on
YouTube please hit the Subscribe button
um we're really gonna make a push for
subscriptions our time watch time has
just gone through the roof
um and the algorithms are getting so
good at just kicking these things out
hit that subscribe button it makes such
a big difference for everybody out there
um and um if you haven't your heart to
leave a five-star review that'd be
awesome too that would be awesome to
share this with everybody
um that you know all right let's go out
to oh don't everyone you know because
you know some people that are kind of
and they probably don't wouldn't take
the show that much all right let's go to
Buffalo Minnesota and talk to Gene
what's up Gene
Hi how are you good I'm feeling extra
singing today I'm sorry I know it's
annoying what's up
not much
just work
overjoyed
oh no I actually loved my job all right
cool so what's up
um so I don't remember exactly what I
said on that email but um oh I don't
have any idea because I don't see it so
you tell me
um I feel like I just cannot keep
friendships like whatever I do in my
life like
yes I can get friends and I'm surrounded
by people and whatever but I just feel
like anyone I get close to all of a
sudden like
I lose that friend and I'm just like I
can never keep a friendship
is there it's not like you've done some
deep digging just to try to figure this
out when you look back and you say like
you get really close to somebody and
then the friendship just goes away
what's a common denominator if you look
back do they tell you you're too intense
do they tell you you don't show up they
just don't like you do you have bad
breath like why why do they end up why
do these friendships end up fading now
oh no I've never talked to people about
it like but you you know though I mean
you're smart
oh no
like I don't know
the reasoning behind it but from how I
see it like yeah
I get close to someone and then like I'm
like oh no they don't actually like me
they don't want to hang out with me they
don't want to be friends with me they're
just being nice to me and whatever and
then I kind of drift away because like
then I'm like okay if I like
distance myself from them maybe they'll
come chasing after me like
they still want to be like they will
come chasing after me because they want
to be friends with me and that just like
and you create a selfie you create a
self-fulfilling prophecy here
yeah you hang out with people you'll
have fun they like you and then you
that little inner machine kicks up
then you decide to put them on trial
decide to test them and you create the
parameters for that test they will only
be my real friend if I distance myself
for them if I leave them and they come
running for me
yeah and people want to honor you if you
run away
I can't imagine the wake of people who
are like I don't know dude Gene's
awesome she just disappeared
yeah
so I just where does where does hold on
where does that voice come from somebody
told you a long time ago that you're not
worth being friends with
who taught you that
anyone that I know of just myself no it
comes from somewhere
because innately
like our our we are biologically wired
to be with other people
like that's our that's our event
something has to happen whether it's a
mom that didn't show up or a dad that
disappears or a parents who tell coach
or an assault whatever happens something
happens that causes a fracture either
acutely like there's a big blow up or it
happens over time
it teaches your body the world would be
better if you were just over here
oh no I know
I don't know very few people say I don't
want to be your friend I want you to get
away from me
they just look at their phone more than
they look at you
they just choose to work 20 hours a day
instead of be with their daughter
they sexually abused somebody like
there's it's usually not a direct thing
but you can't think of any
no you have a great relationship with
your folks
um
like it's not
love them and they're my parents and why
isn't it great
growing up was hard
tell me about that
my parents have been married for 33
years but like I guess more than 33
years
but anyways like they've always been
like at each other's throats and they
like it was non-stop bickering and
whatever and I have 11 other siblings oh
my God Almighty lead with that Gene gosh
it sounds like you grew up in chaos
yeah but I love my family like of course
you do I'm not I'm not trying to say
they're bad I'm not trying to say
anything negative about them
I'm just trying to give you a road map
back as to somehow
what what age order are you in that 11.
I'm Ace you're eight yeah okay
so all right I'm ninth there's no older
than me so you're down there at the
bottom okay
um
for any number of reasons and you and I
could probably unfold this like untangle
it and not take longer than this call
you've come to believe a story that
people don't want to be around you they
don't like you you're not worthy of
their time other people are more
important than you
which then tells your body that other
people are not safe
and when you begin to violate your
body's understanding of other people
aren't safe when you start hanging out
inside the bear cage at the zoo
your body will get your attention
yeah and sometimes people have to drink
in order to be in in proximity of other
folks or to have intimate relationships
some people have to be super adventurous
and busy
some people are pathologically
analytical
you create stories about why they don't
like you and then you create scenarios
that will make your story inevitably
come true
very correct so you ask me how do I make
good friendships
um
you have to decide that I am worth
getting hurt
and before I run out and leave somebody
who's actively hanging out with me and
answering my calls and going and doing
fun stuff together
I'm going to push through that when I
feel my body starting to make these
tests and pull away I am going to
actively lean back in and do something
counteractive here's what that looks
like in my life here's just a simple
example I think I've told this on the
show before
um after a long week of doing media and
doing shows and being on the road and
traveling I get home and I get real real
introverted real fast
like a turtle okay
and I know that's not good for me
because from that I start my diet goes
to crap I just have a whole bunch of
numbing behaviors that I get into so I
have a rule if somebody reaches out to
me and says for instance hey we're all
getting together on Saturday night to
watch the fights and I just got home
and my first thought is I just want to
go to bed
I have to go I have to go
have to go there is no there is no ifs
ins or buts I have to go
and I always go and I've never one time
regretted going
but that's just a rule I put in for
myself
that even when I'm tired if I get
invited out I'm gonna go now that's not
for everybody because some people go out
all the time all the time all the time
and they burn themselves to the ground
that's not my issue
those people need to have the courage to
put up a boundary and say I need to rest
but that's not you
when you feel your body go they just
they just ah they probably just or you
text them and it takes them 10 minutes
to text you back instead of five and you
start cranking up stories in your head
right
yeah yeah
right when that happens just go ah maybe
they have diarrhea
yeah maybe they have to go to the
bathroom so bad there's a long line
somewhere
let reality play out before you or as
brene Brown says stop dress rehearsing
tragedy
yeah stop Imagining the worst case
scenario my gut tells me you're pretty
fun to hang out with is that fair
oh no I I used to be the center of
attention and just like
be like going everywhere anytime just
like center of attention and a loud
obnoxious person and then if you go
where did she go
I lost her where
she came finished
be depressed my mom knew I had
depression for years before I realized
it then it took one night
one night
I just feeling so bad and I just wanted
to die now that night I called a friend
and me
I decided to finally go get help and
then
and then
like I struggled
for years and then one one night I was
like absolutely could not handle it
anymore
and I was
about to just overdose I had the pills
in my hand I was just
holding it shaking it just couldn't
handle it anymore because then I'm like
okay I'm just gonna go to bed and see
what tomorrow brings
and
um I'm gonna just go to bed and see what
tomorrow brings and then
my friend the next day asked me
how long have you been doing and I told
her and then she got scared she knew
I've been struggling sure
she I told her and she got scared so she
told my mom and her mom told my mom
and my mom picked me up from work and
brought me to the mental hospital
and like that was in March of last year
and then
I struggled for a whole nother year and
then
like right after she brought me to the
mental hospital I was so mad at her
like why did you have to put me in that
place I do not want to be there I don't
wanna
whatever and I was so mad at her that I
ended up
ditching her
and then
like a year of struggling and I just
became so
so Within Myself never going anywhere
and
then this year
I was working and somebody I've known
for years but she started working here
and then we just became so close so fast
you know I literally was loving myself
loving my life and life got busy and it
felt like she was way too busy to be
friends with me and I was just like
getting
getting so
like does she even like me does she even
want to be friends with me and just like
getting in my head and then right now
like
we see each other at work and say hi and
smile but that's just about it and I
don't know what like
I don't know how to do this all right
let me back out number one thank you for
telling me that number two
I'm glad you're still here
number three
you can get mad at me and hang up too
but your mom did the exact 100 right
thing I would have done the exact same
thing for my two kids
hold on
of course you did I know you hated it
there those are scary scary places I've
been there too much they're terrifying
okay
and you're still here
yeah
and any parent any day of the week would
rather their kid be mad at them in a
hospital than planning a funeral
yeah okay so
you can get mad at me too but your mom
did the right thing
I know okay number three
you're gonna have to decide
not to not be depressed that's insane
anyone who tells you that just cut them
off you don't be friends with that
person because they're a
yeah but you're gonna have to decide
you're worth feeling better than you
feel
you're going to have to get with a
professional not back at the psych ward
unless you're gonna hurt yourself again
but
with a counselor who can give you some
new skills
because
you have one I have a therapist yeah but
in your case I think there needs to be a
lot less talking and a lot more making
plans and practicing
yeah
you are
um the baseball player that used to hit
home runs all the time and just is
flinching when the ball comes now
that home run hitter is still in there
things just got blurry
is that fair
sometimes we have to practice those
things that we used to do that made us
feel good even we don't feel like doing
those things
and in your case I've said this on a
show a bunch before
um feelings our feelings job is not to
tell us the truth our feelings job is to
Keep Us Alive
and sometimes our feelings don't tell us
the truth
so if reality says if if all of the
external things are this person's
calling me back she's hilarious she
wants to have fun all the time she's
doing all this cool stuff and she's
really busy that's awesome
I feel like she's pulling away from me
doesn't want to be my friend and she
hates me
I think objectively you could go I'm
gonna write that feeling down and I'm
going to examine that feeling is that
feeling telling me the truth
no it's not
is she really busy yeah of course am I
busy yeah of course
but when we get together do the wheels
come off because we have so much fun yup
and when I say doing the work what I
mean is practicing over a period of a
few months
I'm gonna challenge those feelings but
my feelings tell me to shut it down when
my feelings tell me to avoid answering
the phone with my feelings telling my
mom hates me when my feelings tell me
I'm so mad at so and so I'm gonna write
that down in a journal and I'm gonna I'm
gonna call it out are you telling me the
truth
and all of those I write down I'm going
to tell my counselor here's what I wrote
down here's the feelings I wrote down we
go through them with me is that true is
that true couple of them will be true my
friend got really busy she got a big
promotion
so instead of making it all about how
she's not done enough time for me it's
dude I get to celebrate my friend it's
amazing
and on and on and on here's the big
thing I want to pass along to you
your happiness and your joy
and your life
um Essence Force whatever it is I don't
know how to say without saying it
sounded cheesy
is not out there it's in you
it isn't something that you can go get
like I finally found a friend and then I
was the happiest I've ever been no no no
it comes from the inside out
I finally believed I was worth having
fun and I finally started putting myself
out in positions because I love dancing
I'm going dancing
and then I started meeting friends
my body lit up like a Christmas tree
because it was awesome
but somehow a couple years ago and it
could be chemical it could be life
circumstances it could be a loss that we
haven't talked about could be any number
of things
you flip your body flipped that inverted
the switch from outgoing fun silly
goofball Gene to
Zoom live in the feelings living the
feelings living the feelings feelings
become my entire ecosystem my entire
world
and it's just a choice to work with a
professional to say I'm not going to
live in feelings anymore I'm going to
identify them I'm going to feel them but
I'm gonna go do the next thing that I
know is gonna help me be healthy and
over time your body will the sun will
come back out
I promise it will if you stay stay in on
it
promise it will if you stay in on it
so how do you make good like how do you
not overthink your friendships how do
you know if they're good friends or not
let the truth be what the truth is
and when the truth gets cloudy with how
you feel and how you're emotional you
are write those things down and say is
this matching up with reality I feel
like this person hates me but they've
returned my calls every time this week
we've hung out twice last week we're
hanging out again this weekend Okay so
objectively
they don't
my body's just trying to get my
attention for some weird reason hey
buddy we're good I'm driving this car
now we're good
we're good
that Gene is the magic
it's gonna take some time to take some
work some new skills
so so so glad you're here
[Music]
and I'll say this I say this every time
I talk to somebody
if you ever feel like hurting yourself
if you ever feel like not being here
anymore ever feel like taking your life
again
always remember the sun comes up
tomorrow and you have to make that call
you have to make that call you have to
make that call
nobody's life is better if Gene's not
here nobody
thank you for being brave we'll be right
back
this episode is sponsored by betterhelp
hey this is deloney I hope you all are
doing well listen sometimes it's hard to
get our brains to turn off and I know
what I'm talking about I am the king of
racing thoughts they've kept me up at
night they've got me up early and kept
me from connecting with people I love if
you find your thoughts start to race
right before bed or during other super
inconvenient times a great way to make
those racing thoughts slow down or stop
is to talk them through and therapy gave
me a place to do that so I could get off
the negative thought treadmill learn
positive coping skills set healthy
boundaries and find some mental and
emotional peace and it can help you too
if you're thinking of starting therapy
give better help a try better help is
convenient because it's entirely online
so it's flexible and can fit into your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and you can even
switch therapists at any time for no
extra charge so take a break from racing
Thoughts with better help visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right let's go out to H tone and
talk to Chris what's up Chris
hey thanks for taking my call man you
got it what's up man
so uh last week my car actually got
repossessed uh what happened man
uh I knew that I was behind my payments
I just didn't realize how far I was
and uh can I ask you a hard question
came true can I ask you a real hard
question yeah why did you choose to not
know
you made a choice to avoid how bad it
was
yeah yeah I was avoiding it man to avoid
reality how come how come
I guess to to cope with like the stress
from it and uh like the
not having enough money I guess because
I knew I was overpaying it and uh
for the car and uh whenever it got
repossessed I sort of felt almost
relieved in a way of course yeah
you know but uh shame sits in something
fierce huh
you'll see that man bro dude because I
mean it's like it's like the
uh it's the self-fulfilling prophecy
right like I'm gonna avoid it I'm gonna
avoid it I'm gonna avoid it it happens I
told you you were a loser
we shouldn't have bought this car
because we're dumb we don't make enough
money because we're a loser and then the
bank can't even trust us yeah like it's
just a loop right
and then here's your next step and tell
me if I'm wrong the next step is you
wallow in it for a few days you like
make snow angels in the shame and you
figure out a way to numb it out either
you drink it away or you Netflix it away
or you're just going out your Bros in a
way and then you find yourself like
without a car and then the next move is
to go do something stupid like go to a
Payday lender or go to one of those the
guys on the side of the highway that's
at like 35 interest on a car note right
yeah I've been I've been sleeping on it
and uh Chris don't do that don't do that
don't do that don't do that please God
don't do that okay
right okay don't do that like it's all
right the house fell down don't burn it
down you can still put it back up okay
cool
all right before we even get going to
your question I want you to hear
the reason I can just track here's how
this whole thing spins out and here's
where you're about to head and you're
like oh yeah actually
is I've taken this call a jillion times
what does that mean that means you're
not alone that means you did something
dumb but you're not stupid
that means you're in a hole but that's
not where you live you're not a Hobbit
okay
thank you man there's a light on the
back end of this thing you just need to
shake the cobwebs off and I love you
enough to both like kind of give you a
hard time about it and also let's let's
get a roadmap out of here is that cool
yeah all right so um they come and take
your car then what
so uh my parents are my neighbors and my
dad happened to be awake whenever the
guy was uh replenished and I thought he
was going to be mad at me because he had
no idea that I was behind my payments
and I kind of as they were pulling away
I had to explain to
whole thing to the right then and there
and uh
it just surprised me right away he was
like well you got to go to work don't
you you can go ahead and take my car and
uh
when I got to work uh I just tried not
to think about it
and my brother has an extra car and he
said hey you can uh
take uh
take that car and use it to you to save
us some money
and I wasn't I just wasn't expecting
that man and
I in a way it made me feel
really guilty because I'm in this
situation and I have all these people
that want to help me
and hold on that's not what you feel I
don't think that's what it is
I think you feel this weird gnarly sense
of shame because you don't think you're
worthy of that much love
and your old and your old man does and
your brother does
they love you way the hell more than
Chris loves Chris
Fair
yeah yeah
you're right
where did that story come why did Chris
start talking trash to Chris
hahaha
wait
all year I've been trying to better
myself man and uh
work on like my anger issues and
discipline and
self-love uh I got your book back in
March on your past Ginger future
and I had to put it down because it just
started getting really real man yeah
dude you are a master class in avoidance
you can take my life from me you can
take my car for me but I will not look
under the hood man like you bought a new
car and you just duct taped over the uh
the gas gauge I don't wanna know I don't
know
yeah and it's it's really catching up
with me that's right it always does how
old are you
I'm 28. dude you won the lottery man
because it usually catches most people
when they're 51. and their wife leaves
them and they get fired and they got
nowhere to go
yeah I'm excited for you
yeah and like I feel like my my wife
notices that I've changed a lot I
noticed that I changed a lot and like
when we look at old pictures
um
we can see the difference in my face
like I'm not angry like I used to I used
to get and this whole time this whole
past weekend she's been trying to tell
me you know don't stress out don't
don't let it get you mad we'll get
through it like we always do and uh just
great support and this past week was my
my daughter's first week of school and
it was also the day it got repossessed
with our nine-year anniversary together
and I feel like it's it's tainted now
because of this whole situation and this
is where this is where you start this is
your starting line
yeah it's a new starting line that's it
it's not the it's not the it's not where
the race finished this is where the
sucker begins
this is on your 19th anniversary when
you point back you're like remember
where we were
you know what I'm saying yeah you can't
let this this is a big moment right this
is a big moment but you can't let this I
mean bro look what you just rattled off
in front of me
you've been married almost a decade
which is unheard of these days because
people think so little of Covenant
you have a wife that is holding your
hand through hell
you have an old man who's holding your
hand through hell you have a brother who
said here's a car you have a daughter
who's starting school who's healthy
enough to go to school
yeah I'm really grateful man
but all you can think of is I'm such a
loser
that's that's when I'm alone
or when I look at the mirror it's like
that's whenever other it all sits in and
then when I go to my family I sort of
like I don't want to say I fake it but I
I do you fake it with everybody man
you think with everybody
thank you with a bank figure with your
old man think with your brother fake it
with your wife take it with your
daughter and I'll tell you this they all
know
they all know
and they don't know exactly what you're
wrestling with but they know
and I'll tell you like the the big
problem with the like self-help like
Flex it out movement
is that it doesn't it often allows
people to skip over dealing with the
core issue
and then you end up with a hundred
thousand dollars in a six-pack abs and
you freaking hate yourself
and so you have to do those things out
of a sense of I'm worth a different kind
of life
not if I get these things then I'll have
a different life because you won't
you'll the same dude will just show up
the same guy who hates himself will show
up
that makes sense and it sounds so cheesy
to say that bro I trust me I know it
does but it just sounds cheesy but it's
just it's true over and over and over
and over
I remember being in the car when the
head of publishing my buddy Preston
handed me his cell phone with the email
on it that said hey your book has gone
number one
and I was super excited and then
instantly after that he handed that to
me the phone rings and it was Dave my
boss and he calls me and I was so
excited then I called my mom and my wife
I called my wife and then my mom
and then dude I didn't have anybody else
to call
that same lonely dude who tells
everybody to not be lonely showed up
with the number one book in the country
see what I'm saying like I got it and
then and I got it
and I went with me
yeah
so until you you go with you up and you
go with you down
so tell me
what is it about Chris that you wish was
different right now you wish you made
more money you wish your career was
different what is it
no I love my career I make uh I make
decent money what do you do I'm a
machinist
oh so you're one of those guys who can
actually do something with their life
that's pretty cool I love what I do man
dude I'm a podcaster for God's sake you
can build a machine that's amazing man
all right what else
what do you wish I could get my money
right okay
what is it about your money that's
that's off
are you buying stuff to flex out for
people to show them that you're to try
to convince them you're more what is it
no I feel like I've made a lot of bad
decisions in the uh past eight years of
uh
overspending on food and getting loans
here and there buying cars with
ridiculous payments and uh I know but
but
what is that car getting you
nothing I just I at the time I thought
it was a good decision and I got a bad
deal on it and made a mistake and then
started resenting it and trying to hide
from it okay
so step one of All Wellness whether that
you're trying to lose weight whether
you're trying to make money whether
you're trying to get right spiritually
whether you're trying to get right
psychologically and emotionally
is choosing reality I have to choose to
live in reality this is the state of
things
the reason I'm asking about your money
is are you is it like a matter of like I
thought this was a good idea and then I
got into it and oh my gosh
it wasn't a good idea which means it's a
it's it's knowledge it's Insight I don't
have the right Tools in front of me
um I thought this was the right machine
to use and ended up I should have used
this machine is it that or is it impulse
control and you're just kind of acting
like a toddler when it comes to your
money
uh it's a little bit of all like because
I know I do have impulse and I know that
uh
I made like
financing sounds so good in the moment
all right so here's here's how I've
handled financing in my life
um
I will never willingly chain my family
to a bank again
yeah I will never willingly chain myself
to somebody who gives me money for a
depreciating asset which is what a car
loan is every day I own that it's worth
less money and that banknote continues
to stay the same
I just refused to put my I refuse to be
owned
see what I'm saying and so it's not
about like I don't know about Finance I
don't know if that's a good deal no no I
refuse
to participate in
modern day slavery after I refuse to
participate
what does that mean sometimes in my life
the cars I've driven have been so
embarrassing
like bro they're bad like they're back
I've had buddies like take me I'll be
like hey are you okay they're doing
great I don't care about my cars
and I don't spend a lot of money on my
clothes I mean it's like it's and we can
go on and on and on
but my identity is in my wife loves me
my identities and my kids love me and
they're safe my identity is I do a good
job at my job I do good work and I'm a
trustworthy Integris person my identity
is in my faith and so when I have those
things
need a lot of crap but I tell you this
to tell you
there's a map out I'm gonna send you for
free I'm gonna send you all the
Financial Peace University the whole kit
and caboodle and I'm gonna send you
um one year of every dollar okay
it's the best financial tool in the
world and you link it up with your wife
and when both of you spin it goes off
each other's app and it pulls it tells
you from your it can connect with your
bank and does all that together okay
good
you know but what but here's the deal I
want you to watch those lessons with
your wife on the couch and if your kid's
old enough make them sit on and watch
them too so this stuff ends with you
yeah I just I don't want my kids seeing
money is a bad thing and I'm trying
that's part of me like hiding it I guess
but they they here's the deal bro they
feel it
yeah they know Dad can't breathe they
know Dad is stressed and they know Dad
can't sit still in the room because he's
worried and worried and worried and
worried
I grew up in that house
it was in Houston and money was always
always a stressor always
and I grew up hating money because of
what it did to my dad
for what it told me about my family that
we were somehow worth less than my
neighbors
I hated it man
and I'm in my 40s and I'm just now
figuring out money is just a tool that's
it
in a shiny car is cool if you pay for it
in cash and you got a whole bunch of
other assets somewhere otherwise it's
just stupid
see what I'm saying yeah it's a total
flip
but I think beneath all that so I'm
gonna give you the tools on the money
side dude if you will follow those money
principles my promise to you is in 15
years You're Gonna Be a Millionaire
that's probably a little bit over there
you may not be I can't promise you that
you're gonna have a totally different
position okay
but
you have to do the work on making peace
with Chris
because Chris is a good guy
and Chris is a good no no no no no no no
don't do that
you're deflecting again Chris is a good
guy
he's got a good brother and he's got a
good old man and they're not perfect
and he's a good husband
and he's doing his best to be the best
dad he can be even though he doesn't
know what he's doing
and he's made some stupid decisions with
money the difference between guilt and
shame is that was stupid versus I'm
stupid
yeah you're right you did some dumb
stuff all right I'm gonna learn from
that same as when you're trying to teach
an apprentice in the Machine Shop they
do something dumb you're like dude don't
do that again do it like this and they
go ah okay cool
yeah same
at least treat yourself at least talk to
yourself at least love yourself as much
as your dad does much as your brother
does
much as your co-workers do at least if
not more is that fair
yeah that's fair man
it's it's it's tough trying to love
yourself whenever you don't
I guess the expectations you want to be
that's right and so let's be super clear
because a lot of the times this stuff
gets real heavy I want you to spend a
season writing this crap down
like write down the answer to what does
success look like in my home
and if success is has anything to do
with square footage or wheels on a car
that go round and round and round
um you've got that thing sideways
like I mentioned and
I just don't know why I can't just uh be
happy with myself
well I think you've got some confidence
issues man because confidence only comes
from a bunch of little successes and
you've had a bunch of stumbles man you
had a bunch of like man shouldn't have
done that
just like my my wins aren't equally out
to my losses yeah dude
because you keep borrowing money on
depreciating assets and they're not even
paying on it I mean it's not hard it's
pretty all right it's pretty simple
so here's what I want you to do I want
you to get some of your dignity back you
know what that's going to look like it's
going to look like this I want you to
call your brother
and say
um can I have this car for 12 months
and if he's like man that's a long time
like I know I'm gonna pay you I'm gonna
pay you 100 a month and I know that's
not even close to what it's worth
but I need some sort of I gotta have
some skin in the game here so I'm gonna
give you 100 bucks a month
just for renting this car from you
and then I want you to pick up an extra
shift and an extra shift and I want you
to get 3 500 cash as quick as you can
okay and I don't want you I want you to
stay as far away from those stupid Lots
as you possibly can once you get on a
Facebook Marketplace and I want you to
buy a 3500 Camry
and they are going to rag you when you
pull up to that shop oh my gosh they're
gonna give it to you
but you know what you're not gonna owe
nobody nothing
you're right nothing
and you can tell your wife sorry dude
you married me
if you married me for my Tahoe then you
may need to find somebody else because
I'm a camera guy for the season
she's all for it she's very supportive
now
I'm just Clowning of course she is but
look like
I want you to drive around a 3500 Camry
for a seasoned man and make peace with
it
and then save up cash and get an
emergency fund for your family and pay
off all your stupid credit cards
and what we're doing people make this
all about the well it's APR is here and
if you invested this dude we're not
there
we are I'm choosing freedom in my home
Chris in Houston my family will be
holding to nobody if I get fired from my
job it's going to be their loss and I'm
gonna take a week off and kind of check
off the cobwebs and then I'm finding me
a new gig because I got an emergency
fund of my own cash and my own bank
account
I don't need it
I'm squared up
totally squared up
this is about choosing reality here's
the state of things take your wife out
for breakfast one day man
or for lunch God's Papa seed is there in
Houston The Greatest Mexican food places
on planet Earth and just say what do we
want our house to look like and more
importantly what it has to feel like
what does that look like how much money
is that going to require
what kind of cars is that gonna require
it's gonna be a lot different than you
think
let's build a picture together you and
her
and let's start leaning into that and
you're gonna get a bunch of little wins
towards a picture that you and your wife
have chosen a home you have chosen to
build and dude now you are Off to the
Races my friend
and along the way I want you to remind
Chris that you're a good man
you didn't think it was going to feel
like this feels different than you
thought I was going to feel but the
proof is in the pudding got a great wife
got a great kid
got a good family got a home got a roof
over your head you don't owe nobody
anything
you're a good man Chris
I'm grateful for you brother thanks for
calling call anytime and uh hang on the
line I'm gonna send you a copy of
building a non-anxious life too and all
the FPU gear and I need you because I'm
not there I need you to at least get
yourself to at least one Astros game and
cheer man we're getting close to not
making the playoffs and I'm gonna hold
you accountable for it my brother we'll
be right back
if you've listened to my show any amount
of time you've definitely heard me talk
about Thorn Thorne is an incredible
supplement company that makes what I
think are the best supplements in the
game I've taken Thorn for years way
before I had a show as you've probably
heard from listening to other podcasts
or just walking through a local corner
store there are a million different
supplements all claiming the next great
thing for all sorts of ailments almost
all of those claims and products are
either lying not good products or just a
waste of your money Thorne is one of the
very few supplement companies that make
Pure Clean tested and backed by science
supplements no fluff no gimmicks no
nonsense Thorn is what I take personally
and it's what I give to my kids and make
no mistake supplements of this quality
cost more than the nonsense you see in
gas stations so I've partnered with
Thorne for an incredible 25 off discount
for our deloney show listeners go to
thorn.com you slash deloni choose what
you want add it to your cart create an
account and when you check out 25 off
will be knocked off of the entire order
and here's the best part that discount
sticks around for Life go to thorn.com
the letter U slash deloni check it out
all right let's go out to Carol in
Georgia what's up Carol
hey it's so nice to be talking with you
today thank you for taking my call oh
goodness thank you for calling me and
I'm kind of in a singing mood still I'm
trying to stop Kelly says it's annoying
people write in comments and you quit
singing
is my singing back you're fine all right
no you're good all right what's up Carol
okay uh I'm trying to figure out how to
lose weight and keep it off permanently
After experiencing those sexual trauma
oh gosh what happened and the back story
I was raped uh when I was 16 years old I
was being in a size five seven
after years of yo-yo dieting I'm now 44.
uh yeah over half my life
um and then a size 18 20. in the past I
could lose some weight however every
time I received any kind of attention
from a man as little as a look or a
small or anytime I was planning an event
trip holiday uh get together Etc I would
gain weight and didn't realize I was
doing this to myself until a couple of
years ago
and now that I I know I still cannot
seem to break the cycle and on top of
that I was in a vehicle accident six
years ago that caused a lot of issues
with my body making it even harder to
exercise or do any kind of physical
activity any length of time without
being in excruciating pain
so I'm in desperate need of your help Dr
Don Delaney Delaney sorry yeah oh you're
okay
my wife says my name wrong too still
after 25 years it's fine
hmm
I
I guess I'll just start with I'm so
sorry that happened
thank you
I'm so sorry that somebody took that
everything away from you
especially taking away how safe you feel
inside your own body
um
and I'm also sorry for
almost 30 years of
just painful loneliness right
I'm so sorry
um my experience is is
you're going to need somebody different
than me but I'm going to walk you I'm
gonna hold your hand and walk you to
that person okay is that cool
that's perfect okay
um
so most common is what the literature
would tell me okay is that
after a sexual assault
there can be a couple of different paths
when it comes to weight gain
sometimes it is
I want to hide inside myself I want to
disappear in a crowded room kind of like
my daughter she's seven she'll put her
hair over her eyes and kind of feel like
she's disappeared even though she's
standing right there
and kind disappear
or I can put some some safety between me
and the outside world
there's often another piece of this
train that I think is is more Insidious
and that it's somehow some way the story
gets twisted up inside of somebody that
this is what they get
that this is what they deserve
it's almost a form of self-punishment
look at what you did last time look at
what you allowed to happen last time
look at the role you played in what
happened last time you that's what you
get
so if you've honestly looked I mean it
sounds like you've I mean you're way
ahead of most folks that I sit down with
in this with this this challenge
when you look back
and you go oh gosh every time every time
I get close to somebody every time I
start to be around other people
I just without even thinking I start
using food to numb out and then it's got
some pretty significant Health
consequences for me
um when you look back
um
what is your body trying to keep you
safe from
being hurt
okay
is there any sort of guilt here or are
you able to separate yourself from any
sort of this is on somebody else
somebody else took this from you that
you didn't play a role in that
I'm sure the other skill
what's the guilt from
tell me the guilt story
I guess
it wasn't a person that worked with my
dad if he'd come to the house so
I mean he was a Oh I
I would consider a family friend but I
guess if I wouldn't have got in the
vehicle nope nope nope nope it's gonna
stop you right there Carol
no you're a kid
you're a kid
that man stole from you
okay
yeah
when you lose weight
does it make you feel vulnerable naked
on a street corner if you will
yeah exposed okay
I mean of course when I'm bigger like I
am now I won't
to lose the weight of course if you want
to be healthy but then when I get there
if I get any luck or attention it scares
me yeah
all right I'm going to walk you through
a few steps and I'm going to direct you
where you need to go next okay
okay all right
um and so for people listening by the
way
it's I I totally get it it's very easy
to to think man
you'll feel so much better if you're
right
and
it's a feeling of Terror that if you
haven't been through some sort of sexual
assault or sexual trauma that it's hard
to even put into words
in fact your body takes over and you
even you even spoke of it as an
out-of-body experience almost you wake
up a month later and you've put on 35
pounds
right
it's almost so automated or so
mind-numbing that your body starts to
save your life from yourself because
it's so put a pin in Intimacy in
relationships that it goes running right
uh-huh okay
all right so here's step one
I want you to hear what I'm gonna say
and I'm going to be pretty direct
because we only have a few minutes okay
and normally I'd be a lot slower to say
some of the things I'm going to say but
they're pretty direct okay
is that cool and a lot of them you
probably know but maybe no one's ever
said them to you before okay
this is not keeping you safe
and in fact
this is killing you slowly
I agree completely okay
the second thing is and this is going to
be hard and this is going to be
something you have to unpack with a
counselor do you promise you will talk
to somebody
yes okay
we are going to commit from this day
forward
that we will not give that man one more
second of your life
yes no more
no more keeping ourselves safe from that
guy
surely he's long dead by now
hopefully okay
he does not get one more inch of real
estate in your heart anymore
he's still winning
he still cast a shadow and that ends
today
okay
yes now I know that's easy to say out
loud and there's going to take some
significant trauma counseling to work
through it not significant in time I
think you can do it relatively quickly
over the course of 10 or 11 or 12 weeks
but
significant like it's gonna be tough
it'll be tough
but if anybody knows tough it's Carol in
Georgia right
amen that's right I'm fighting you ain't
no way okay step two
I want you to recognize you were not
safe then
when that predator of a man came into
your house
and took from you your innocence your
safety
your ability to get close he stole that
from you
you weren't safe then but you're safe
now
and that sentence is going to be
critical to you getting well
so when your body starts to try to
protect you in the present
from a thing that happened 30 years ago
we're gonna stop and we're gonna say out
loud I wasn't safe then but I'm safe
right now
I'm Carol from Georgia I'm safe right
now
okay
yes all right
you're gonna have to decide over time to
catch those feelings in progress in
action and sometimes that will be
halfway through a cheeseburger I don't
know what your food of choice is mine is
candy and cheeseburgers I catch myself
halfway through a cheeseburger and I
will throw the whole thing out oh my
gosh I am mindlessly doing this
I've been on the phone with somebody in
the middle of a business call trying to
make a thing and I pulled into a
drive-through I'm just going down I'm
going down a rabbit hole here
caught it and then I asked myself what's
my body trying to protect me from oh
I'm kind of ashamed that I might not get
the speaking gig or they they can't meet
my rate or whatever the thing is that my
body's trying to protect me from
it's just a practice to catch it
you can't see this unless you're white
because we're on the phone but I
actually have like a a journal that I
carry with me it's it's the thoughts I
just write them down
that way I can just examine them is this
true or is this not true
and then over time with the counselor
you're going to learn some new traits
some new skills instead of
eating those feelings we're going to
walk those feelings
we are going to call a friend those
feelings we're going to show up to a
groups those feelings
we're going to read a book those
feelings we're gonna have a cup of
coffee a cup of tea we're going to
figure out other avenues for those
feelings that make sense
yes
here's where that's a huge paradigm
shift for you
you're not broken there's nothing wrong
with you your body's doing exactly what
it should it is trying to protect you
from that hell ever happening again and
it's done a great job right it's done a
shop
uh-huh
and it's cost you everything right yes
yes okay so what we have to do is we
have to open up our toolkit of which
there's only one tool and that is avoid
all relationships period
okay that worked that kept us safe and
it's killed us too so we're going to put
some new Tools in that bag
that's it
and I don't want you to look at this as
though you have some sort of character
issue or some sort of willpower issue
you just need some different Tools in
that bag that you got to practice using
that's all
okay okay
I want you to honor your body for having
kept you safe for for 30 years
okay and be really pissed off that it
shows that way all right that's right it
could have chose Marathon running that
uh I saw recently there's a significant
number of of
um endurance athletes that also had
significant trauma
okay
it's equally un I mean it's equally not
good
but it's just the body's response and so
hey buddy you kept me safe
I really hate how you did this but you
kept me safe
right
uh-huh I got this from my good buddy Sal
DiStefano who works with the Mind pump
guys and I want you to hear me really
closely
you cannot hate your body into being
healthy
you can't disgust yourself into being
healthy you can't
you have to honor it you've got me safe
thank you you thank you
and now we're going to learn safety in a
new way because this way is going to
kill me
and it's going to keep me lonely it's
going to keep me filling the plane step
three you're gonna have to begin
practicing becoming aware when you grab
food when you're isolating
and this isn't about fighting yourself
this is about one word awareness
that's it
okay
and if you will do the work of writing
them down in a journal and when I say
Journal like nine bucks at Walmart have
somebody go get it for you right nine
bucks
um
as you write them down you'll start to
see a pattern
every time my dad calls I reach over and
grab something to eat
every time it gets past eight o'clock
and I'm lonely I grab something to eat
every time I finish I get nervous at
work or whatever the thing is
and those will be your trigger points
curious why is my body trying to protect
me from that
you see what I'm saying
and I want you to hear how light My
Touch is on all of this you have fought
yourself for 30 years right
yes you've hated yourself for 30 years
right
you've been grossed out for 30 years
yes see we make can we make one
agreement that's not working
right let's try something else
yes
it's the same thing I tell parents who
are screaming at their kids and
screaming at their kids screaming at
their kids take out the trash tail trash
make her bed
when I finally say hey that's not
working what if we tried something else
and that's all I'm asking you 've tried
the hammer method you tried the scream
method you've tried the I hate you
method you've tried the starvation
method you've tried to all work this off
method let's start with the I love Carol
method
and thank God for keeping me safe
yes
and now let's move on step four is going
to be to seek out a daily weekly group
of people that you care about whether
that's an Overeaters Anonymous whether
that's a counselor whether that's a
group of women they get together for
coffee somewhere at a local place
I'm convinced beyond a shadow of a doubt
there is no healing especially from
trauma and isolation you have to be with
other people
and okay what makes trauma so ugly is it
makes the one it makes oxygen poisonous
it makes oxygen feel poisonous
right
when you start getting close to people
that's when your body says run right
that's what you're gonna have to go
through that's the alarm you're gonna
have to head directly into kind of like
your kitchen that smoke alarm goes off
you don't run out in the yard you go see
what the alarm what's setting the alarm
off
that's what we're doing here
okay you know
I mean with a group of friends once a
week that sets off your alarms cool then
I'm gonna make sure we're doing that
or I'm gonna go to Overeaters Anonymous
I'm gonna go to uh whatever group I'm
gonna go be with people
slowly slowly slowly at first right
yes
and I'm going to suggest and this is
going to give me some hate on the
internet saying I don't care
um I don't think it's time for exercise
yet
okay okay
I don't think it's I don't think we're
there yet if you could go for a walk
every day I think that would be dramatic
for your body and your mind and your
soul
but if you can okay don't
cool
perfect
um you may be ready to rock and roll
like no no I want to get an exercise
program and get this get go to physical
therapy and get some PT and get this
pain under control cool that's great
but I don't want you to try to look in
the in the mirror and stare at yourself
and hate yourself forward on that
treadmill
I want you to think we've been kept safe
for this long now we're moving into part
two
that took way longer than we thought but
we're moving into part two which is
I love this body that has kept me safe
for 30 years so much I'm going to make
sure it's around for another 40.
right I am exercising because I get to
because that guy has not one more inch
inside of my heart
he will not keep me isolated anymore he
will not keep me alone anymore anymore
anymore here's step five this is the
hardest part have you ever been to
counseling yet
oh
okay most of my family and friends don't
even know what happened
grief demands a witness
as the great David Kessler says you have
to say these things out loud and here's
what I almost guarantee has happened
inside of you
when you told me what happened
I'd be willing to bet your shoulders
dropped a little bit and it felt
[Applause]
and then over the course of this call
your body has filled back up with it
with with
air oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh oh
my gosh is that right
and then when you get off this call
you're gonna have a I can't believe I
said that I can't believe I said that I
can't believe I said that
you're gonna have to find somebody that
you can sit down and be honest and tell
the story to so I want you and your
local community I want you to reach out
to somebody
and say
I was sexually assaulted and raped as a
teenager and it's continuing to
um
have a powerful hold on me into my 40s
and I'm ready to let this go I would
like to explore trauma counseling what
does that mean might be EMDR
it might mean Bodywork which is what I
had done did and it was extraordinary
that's that's a whole other conversation
we could have another time
it's it might be a some sort of
adult-centric seeking safety program it
might be an rdbt program it might be any
number of things the modality I don't
care so much about but somebody that
will walk through and teach you a set of
skills for self managing when your body
takes off on you and then head back
through that trauma
and then the Peace and Freedom on the
other side of it
and there's going to be guilt and I
can't believe it went on this all that's
part of the healing
you're worth all of it
we're going to clip this I'm going to
send it to you Carol
um just
so that you don't have to wait for a
month until this show comes out
um I'm also going to send you a copy of
my book own your past change your future
want you to read that book it doesn't
speak specifically to White game but it
does talk about healing from trauma just
the path out and how these stories get
lodged in US
and I want you to before today is over I
want you to call counselor and I want
you to call one or two women that will
go and have coffee with you
and if you're brave you can say the
story out loud you don't just say names
you don't say anything like that but you
can say the story out loud and be heard
for the first time
it'll be scary it'll be hard and
that's the first step towards this not
holding you anymore don't have a grip on
you anymore I'm free from this
[Music]
I am free
I'm so grateful for you Carol I'm so
proud of you I'm so proud of you for not
giving up on you and saying all right
cool 44. today is when everything
changes
Carol you call me anytime anytime I'm
here for you I'm you your bravery has
inspired me today we'll be right back
hey Dr John deloney here I'm super
jazzed to announce my new book building
a non-anxious life is now available for
pre-order listen we all experience some
level of anxiety or stress or burnout
every day but most of us don't know how
to recognize it let alone deal with it
and here's the good news anxiety doesn't
have the last word I know this because
I've sat with thousands of you and I
know this because I've been there too
if you create a life of intentionally
living out the six daily choices I've
outlined in this book you'll be able to
better respond at whatever life throws
at you this book will help you learn
practical steps to overcome anxiety plus
when you pre-order the book now I'm
gonna give you something to help you
today that's why you'll instantly get my
newest talk smoke fire and freedom where
I break down the misunderstandings and
myths we believe about anxiety how to
reclaim your freedom and how to build a
non-anxious life so pre-order building a
non-anxious life today for just 20 bucks
at John deloney.com
all right as you wrap up today's show
Randy Newman because Kelly's 114. songs
by rain how old is Randy Newman
laughs
oh this is a song that uh Kelly used to
listen to and she was it's from
in college oh is it it's a Toy Story
theme song oh sorry jeez
I don't doesn't rain anymore make peanut
butter cups or something
Paul just read the lyrics Paul Newman
and that's salad dressing just read the
lyrics
Randy Newman You Got a Friend in Me
You Got a Friend in Me Kelly When the
road looks rough ahead and your miles
and miles from your nice warm bed
just remember your old pal said You Got
a Friend in Me
you may be really really old
but you've got a friend that's not that
Line's not in there you got a friend in
me
[Music]
if you're listening to this show
and even if you're not you got a friend
in me too I'm glad you're here I'm
grateful for you bye
[Music]
foreign